also breaking tonight texas governor
greg abbott issued an executive order
restricting the transportation of
migrants due to covert 19.
he joins us now with more governor this
has been an extraordinarily
challenging legal issue for you
in as much as the when the federal
government does not enforce the law of
the land
there have been legal precedent
precedents
preventing you from doing so that has
now
resulted in you now spending and
allocating
250 million dollars to build the wall
but now more importantly as a result of
the pandemic
you now have a legal remedy available to
you that maybe you didn't have before
i do uh two actually two uh one that i
triggered
uh pursuant to the texas constitution
i've authorized the texas national guard
to
perform law enforcement functions up
until now they have been
assisting the texas department of public
safety they've been assisting in the
process of
clearing the land and getting the land
ready for the border wall
as well as other activities like that
however because of manpower needs
we need to have the national guard not
just engage to assist
but to engage to arrest that will lead
to the jailing
of the people who are coming across the
border illegally now on top of that what
you just talked about my new executive
order today
this stems from what sarah was talking
about but what happened yesterday
in la jolla texas where it was learned
that migrants had been released by
border patrol
they were in la jolla found at a
whataburger with extreme
signs of illness and they themselves
said
they had covered 19 and then it was
learned there was a hotel
full of people with coba 19 and that's
exactly why i issued this executive
order
it does a couple of things one is it
empowers the texas department of public
safety
to stop any vehicle where there is a
suspicion
that that vehicle may be transporting
migrants into and around the state of
texas who may have covered 19.
and second it orders the department of
public safety to return that vehicle
to either the point of origin which
would be where the
uh border patrol officers let them go
or to the port of entry and so i have a
job to protect the safety and health of
the people of state of texas
and that includes especially now
preventing president biden
from importing coba 19 into texas as
well as into
to the united states governor can you
explain
now the biden cdc policy
of they're now supporting mandating
vaccines for americans
and even if you're vaccinated they're
telling you again now that you've got to
put your mass back on
all simultaneously allowing hundreds of
thousands of illegal immigrants that we
know about
every month cross the border uh
many of them with a very high rate of
covert positivity
and then dispersing him to the other the
continental 48
states in the u.s um how why are they
not as onerous
on on people that are not respecting our
laws
our borders and our sovereignty i mean
that's that this is a
this is madness to me so
obviously it's hypocritical but
obviously it shows that
the vitamin rushing care is more about
people who are not residents of america
than he does of the residents of america
because
he has one standard trying to mask up
and vaccinate our fellow americans
but by allowing free pass into the
united states of people
with a high probability of covet and
then spreading that covet of in our
communities
as has been shown in the rio grande
valley so
what the bio administration is doing is
deadly it's dangerous and it must be
stopped
and that's what my executive order that
issue today tries to achieve
governor thank you all right hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else